.
TESTING ONE TWO MIKE TEST ONE
TWO. OKAY. TESTING ONE TWO ONE
TWO THREE YES. ONE TWO ONE TWO
MIKE TEST ONE TWO. MY TEST ONE
TWO ONE TWO. TESTING ONE TWO
YEAR MOVEMENT TO. TESTING ONE
TWO.
AFTER THAT WE JUST
COMPLETED. THOROUGH BRIEFING
GOVERNOR DUCEY. HERE IN
ARIZONA- ABOUT THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THE RISING. OF THE
WIRELESS BASES. SURE IF YOU
REFLECTIONS ON WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM. BEFORE THAT LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT TO REFLECT. ANOTHER
ASPECT THIS DAY. HUGE WIN FOR
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA. FOR
AMERICA WORKERS FARMERS AND
RANCHERS THAT IS THAT. AS OF
TODAY THE U. S. MCA HAS TAKEN A
FACT. IT IS I AM TOLD. THIS IS
A THIS STATE IN FOR. LET'S SEE
TRADE WITH MEXICO CANADA TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
JOBS. TWENTY DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
LET'S TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
PARTICULARLY TO THANK GOVERNOR
DOUG DUCEY THE FORMER IS
AFTERWARDS. YOU SMCA THREE
CONFERENCE AS A CANDIDATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP. COMMITTED TO
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA IN A WAY THAT
PUT AMERICAN JOBS AND AMERICAN
WORKERS FARMERS AND RANCHERS
FIRST. ON THAT. US. YOU HAVE A
SIX YEAR STUDY. AS TRUMP FAST
JUST TO BE HERE TODAY. AMANDA
GREISER CORONAVIRUS CASES IN
ARIZONA SHE WILL BRIEFING.
ABOUT THE STATE'S RESPONSE. I
WANT TO SAY FIRST AND FOREMOST
TWO GOVERNOR DUCEY. THE VERY
FIRST DAYS OF THIS ENDEMIC.
YOUR LEADERSHIP OUR TEAM IN
ARIZONA IS REALLY FOR. A
SEAMLESS PARTNERSHIP. WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE PROMOTERS NATIONAL. AND
UP UNTIL REP THREE WEEKS AGO.
ARIZONA HAD LITERALLY SET THE
PACE. CANCELING THE SPREAD
FLATTENING THE CURVE AND KNOW
WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK YOU.
THIRTEEN AND TO ALL THE PEOPLE
ARIZONA FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS.
THE PAST FOUR MONTHS. BUT THE
WITH CASES. DRAMATICALLY NOT
JUST HERE AMERICO COUNTY BUT-
BECAUSE THERE IS ONLY ONE OF
THE BIGGER TO GET A REPORT FROM
THE GROUND. TAKE BACK WELL WE
HEARD HERE TODAY. SURE THE TEAM
THAT WE BROUGHT WITH US
INCLUDING ACTING SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY OVERSEAS OF
THE NATURE THERE'S UNIQUE WHEN
YOU NEED IT. THE GOVERNOR TODAY
WE SAY TO THE PEOPLE. WITH YOU.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT.
WHATEVER TAKE. AT THIS MOMENT.
READ THE PRESS BUTTON THE SAME
LINE. EACH AND EVERY ONE OF WE
ALSO FROM HELLO WHO IS
COORDINATED. ALL OF THE PD'S
THE CONCERN OF METAL WELL WE'RE
HERE TODAY. THAT'S THE-
HOSPITAL HERE REMAIN STRONG ON
SOME AND EQUIPMENT WE DID HEAR.
AND BRIEFING TODAY THE FIRST.
ALREADY RISK SIXTY TWO MEDICAL
PERSONNEL ARRIVE THIS WEEK. ON
THE GOVERNOR CAMPAIGN TO US.
WAS ANOTHER FIVE ON FIRST. AND
I'M INSTRUCTED. HOMELAND
SECURITY MOVE OUT IMMEDIATELY
ON PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DOCTORS
AND NURSES AND TECHNICAL
PERSONNEL. ALL THE INCREDIBLE.
HERE IN ARIZONA HELP IS ON THE
WAY. AND WE'RE GONNA SPARE NO
EXPENSE FIVE. KIND OF
REINFORCEMENT. THAT YOU WON'T
NEED ALL ACROSS THE STATE THIS.
IS CORONAVIRUSMAY IN THE
ARIZONA AS I SAID WE OF. WE'RE
ENCOURAGED HOSPITAL CAPACITY
REMAINS MANAGEABLE IN 8885% OF
MEDICAL BILLS. ONLY 88% I SEE
YOU. THE GOVERNOR AND I ALSO
SPOKE TODAY. ABOUT TWO
ADDITIONAL FACILITIES THAT WERE
ALREADY REVIEWED AND DEVELOPED
BY COURT. HELLO DAN THOSE.
RESULT SHORT ORDER IF YOU NEED
SUGAR. MAKE SURE THAT. ARIZONA
CONTINUES. THE HEALTHCARE
CAPACITY IN THE STATE. EVERYONE
THIS LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE THAT
WE WOULD WANT ANYONE OF OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS. FINALLY LET ME
SAY. I COULDN'T BE MORE
GRATEFUL. THIS OUTLETS GRETCHEN
AND- THE CASE IS RISING IN THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS. WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE STEPS THE GOVERNOR
DOUG DUCEY. LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS ARE HIM. THE STATE OF
ARIZONA TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
ARIZONA ALL. LANKFORD EARLY ON
IN THIS PANDEMIC. WE ALL
NOTICED SOMETHING CHANGE ABOUT
THE MIDDLE OF MAY AND- THAT'S
WHAT IS GOING A STEP FORWARD.
SITES ACTION WITH THE HELP OF
THE PEOPLE OF ERRORS ON THE
FIRST PRESIDENT TRUMP MICHAEL'S
SUPPORTERS. A LARGE GATHERING
POSSIBLE OF LARGE. MOVIE
THEATERS WATER PARKS SHARKS.
AUGUST PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I
OUR TASK FORCE OR APPS
COMMITTED. SUPPORT YOUR EVERY
RISK. RIGHT MOST OF ALL. SO
THAT WE CAN OUR ECONOMY WILL BE
FORWARDED GET OUR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL. CD'S POSTED REVENUE
GUIDANCE FOR GETTING OUR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL YESTERDAY POST
MIDNIGHT OPENING UP CALLS.
OVERNIGHT YESTERDAY THE
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE. OF US
MOVING FORWARD. GET OUR KIDS
BACK IN CLASSROOMS UNLESS. IT'S
BEEN A- TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS THE FIRST. M. L. CARE
WORKERS. JOB LEARN RECENTLY AT
THIS HOUR. ACTIVE CORONAVIRUS
BUT I WANT SAY IT ALL GOOD
PEOPLE THERE WAS A WE ALL TO DO
OUR- EVERY YEAR IS ONLY. TO
HEAR THE GUY. IS AN ALL THE GUY.
OF LOW AUTHORITIES. ZERO SIX
POLICE YOUNG OVER INFORMED
TODAY THAT THERE COPA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT HEALTH. IT MORE THAN
50% OF ALL OF THOSE ARE JUST.
AMERICA CANNOT. ARE UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTY FIVE. YOUNG
PEOPLE. HELLO THAT WITHOUT ANY
HEALTH ISSUES RIGHT NOW THE
SERIES OUTCOME FOR THE
CORONAVIRUSMAY REMAINS.
REMINDER YOUNG PEOPLE. IF YOU
SEE THE MAIN OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INTO PLACE YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
CALL FOR COMMON SENSE PERSONAL.
MOST ONE. OKAY THREE TWENTY
SOMETHINGS IN MY FAMILY AND I
KNOW THEY GO YOUNG PERSON HERE
IN ARIZONA WOULD WANT TO END IT
FOR LATE EXPOSE OTHER. ELDERLY
NEIGHBOR MOM OR DAD. EACH OF
THEM WE TO COME ALL THE STEPS
THE GOVERNOR'S WE WANT TO
REMIND YOU. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
ALL OF US PARTICULARLY. AMONG
US TO REMEMBER WASH YOUR HANDS.
RIGHT WHERE MASS WHEN INDICATED
BY STATE OR LOCAL FOR OR SOCIAL
THIS. THIS WEEK ALL OUR PART.
ALL THIS SAY BLACK REMEMBER
IT'S NOT EITHER OR- IF YOU SET
UP JUST A FEW SHORT. PUBLISHED
OPEN UP OUR OUR ECONOMY WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THEM AS A
GENERAL UP MORE WE ALL. SUPPORT
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES THAT ARE
PUT INTO EFFECT. OR WE CAN GET
IT. OKAY THAT'S WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER AND TOGETHER ARE
VERY. ALL OF US EACH AND EVERY
DAY. SLOW THE SPREAD. LET WE'LL
SAVE A LOT. ALL ACROSS THIS
STATE WE PLAY FOUNDATION FOR
BREAKING THINGS BACK BIGGER AND
BETTER THAN EVER THANK YOU FOR
MUCH GOVERNOR DO. THANK YOU FOR
DELIVERY. WITH. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU MR VICE PRESIDENT
FOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WHILE THIS PANDEMIC
IT'S WAS GREAT TO SEE YOU TODAY
IN PERSON. WHAT I'M ABLE TO SEE
YOU AT LEAST ONCE TWICE A WEEK
ON COUNCIL COMMUNICATION WE
HAVE FOR THE VIRUS YES WE VERY
MUCH. YOUR AND FROM COMMITMENT
TO SERVING ARIZONA AND HELPING
US SOLVE THE ISSUES THERE IN
FRONT OF US TODAY I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE CORONAVIRUS.
SECRETARY GENERAL. ON MOBILE
JACK WHO IS TALK TO US ABOUT
SUPPLIES DR DEBORAH. S. FOR
SEVERAL DAYS IN ARIZONA MEETING
WITH LEADERS MAKERS AND
INFLUENCERS IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY ACROSS OUR STATE AND
ACTUALLY SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS THE SOUTHWEST
INCLUDING NEW MEXICO. AND TEXAS
WERE GRATEFUL FOR WHAT SHE'S
BEEN ABLE TO CONTRIBUTES TO THE
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS SHE WAS
ABLE TO ANSWER GUIDANCE SHE WAS
ABLE TO CLARIFY I ALSO WANT TO
THANK JENNA. WATER AND DOCTOR.
EXPRESS THIRTY. FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE HARD WORK
THAT AND THEN DOING FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO SAY. THANK YOU
YOUR CARE WORKERS WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES. ERRORS ARE
NURSE. IN OUR HOSPITALS. AND
ALL OF OUR GIVER. DECISIONS WE
ARE OUR HELP YOU HELP PEOPLE IN
ARIZONA THEY NEED TO LEARN IS
CLEAR IN TERMS OF WHERE IT IS
TODAY. YOU SAFER. ALL WE WANT
TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF THIS
VIRUS. THE MOST VULNERABLE WE
HAVE TAKEN THE STEPS IT
TEMPORARILY LOWERS BONNER'S AND
GM HEADWATER PARKS. AND
MOVEMENT YES. THIS FOR A LONG
TIME. VERY GOOD JOB ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE THOSE THAT ARE SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OR OLDER AND AT
HIGHER RISK PRODUCTS HEALTH
ISSUES WE NOW LEAVE THE MESSAGE
SPREAD FAR AND WIDE THAT WE ALL
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO SLOWING THE
SPREAD. OF THIS VIRUS. A SAFER
PLACE FOLLOW THE FUND. MASS UP.
WASHING YOUR HANDS MAINTAINING
THAT PHYSICAL DISTANCE BETWEEN
OTHERS AND WHEN YOU'RE SICK
STAYING HOME IF WE COMMIT TO
THAT. WOULD INCREASE THE
INTENSITY OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS. YEAH DEFINITELY BETTER.
IN ARIZONA SO WITHOUT AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHATEVER WE
HAVE ASKED FOR A NEEDED WHETHER
WAS INCREASE FAST. FURTHER
SUPPORT ON CONTACT. YEAH IS OUR
DO YOU SLEEP ANSWER HAS YES AND
WHAT URGENCY IN ADDITION TO
HELPING CLARIFY SOME FEDERAL
GUIDANCE. HOSPITAL ARE ON THE
GROUND WITH SUPPORT AND
RESEARCH SO I COULDN'T BE MORE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AND LEADERSHIP IN THIS BATTLE
IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
REMAIN VIGILANT. AND ALSO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY. LOCAL LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE CREDIBLE JOB
KADING. THAT IT FITS WHAT ON A
MAN AND HOW THEY ACT HELP OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS SLOW VIRUS AND
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN THE
PODIUM OVER THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WHO IS. OUR
IS WELL ON EVERY IN THERE IS.
NEEDED DENTAL THE FOCUS FOR.
WHATEVER ISSUES WE'VE HAD AT
THE BORDER AS WELL THAT WE'RE
GRATEFUL COMFORTABLE. THE FIRST
START OFF BY. AS FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP OF THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE. WE PUT TOGETHER
SEVERAL ARE HERE TODAY. REALLY
DID OUTSTANDING JINPING
GOVERNOR DUCEY. LEADERSHIP OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL AT UC CASES
INCREASE HERE AGAIN YOU KNOW
YOU CALL TO GATHER AS WELL. WE
SUPPORT ARIZONA AND ALL THE
STATE'S. ENERGY TO RESPOND.
OBLIGATED ONE NINETEEN. ARIZONA
OR NATIONAL GUARD OPERATION FOR
ALTERNATIVE FACILITIES AND
OTHER EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE
MEASURES WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WE ALSO SAY THAT AGAIN.
CHECK OUT THREE DIFFERENT ABLE
TO SEND OVER THREE AND EIGHTEEN
MILLION UNITS OF THE NEEDS OF
THE STATE OF ARIZONA AS WELL
CONTINUE TO SEARCH. AS AS WE
NEED TO DO THAT AS WELL. IN THE-
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT- ANY
THREATS THAT ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER WE PUT IN SOME.
INITIAL RESTRICTIONS SEVERAL
MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SLOW THE SPREAD. WALK KEEPING A
SENSUAL TRAFFIC NATURALE.
BECAUSE YOUR SOUTHERN ONE OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER ARIZONA
SOUTHERN BORDER ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO THE ECONOMIES ALONG
THAT BORDER INTO THE U. S.
ECONOMY. ENSURE THAT WE GET
THAT RIGHT. AT ONE A DAY BY DAY
BY WEEK BASIS IF THERE'S ANY.
CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO MAKE.
CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT THAT AT
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE JUSTIN
AGAIN THANKING THE GOVERNOR-
FOR HIS EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND I WILL SAY- AS WE
DEAL WITH THE PAIN. INCIDENTS
THAT ARE GOING OUT. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. FINALLY IN THESE AS
IT IS THE COUNTRY LARGEST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AIDE AND SO WE
READY TO SERVE OUR STATE LOCAL.
THANK YOU MONUMENTS STATUES AND
LIGHTS AT BEGIN THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS WORK AS WELL. THE LAST
YEAR DAYS. WHAT IS IT
REMARKABLE HE IS WATCHING THE-
RESPOND TO THE- I. HERE THAT WE
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER WEARING I
SAW THAT WHEREVER I FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL DAYS AND I WANT TO
THANK PEOPLE OF ARIZONA. WE
DON'T. MEETING ACTIVELY. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THEY ARE OTHER
IN AND I WANT TO. AT THE OF IT
THAT OF THESE. THAT WAS ISSUES
INCREASING YOUR TEST POSITIVITY
RATE. PROTECT ONE ANOTHER. IS
IT REALLY INCREASE OUR RATE NOT
ONLY IN RESPECT FOR ONE ANOTHER.
CASEY COMING FROM HIS HOUSE
THAT. WILL CHANGE IS. CLEAR
THAT WITH THIS IN TIME CLOSING
THE PHARMACY. ON OTHER ACTIONS
REALLY WE HAVE. ARE MILLENNIALS
AND GEN Z. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SHOWING
HOW IMPORTANT THE MASS AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING OUR
COMMUNICATION THAT YOU'RE
HAVING WITH YOUR PARENTS AND
YOUR GRANDPARENTS TO PROTECT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN YOUR AGE
GROUP. EVERY THE EXISTING
CONDITION. THEY HAVE DIABETES
THEY HAVE HYPERTENSION. NO
MATTER WHAT THEIR AGE ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE. THE HOSPITAL. HERE
NOT ONLY PROTECTING THOSE WE-
AT THE OVER SIXTY FIVE AGE
GROUP ONE ANOTHER AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YESTERDAY I.
THE ENTIRE GROUP. THE
GOVERNOR'S AND THE HEALTH.
UNDERSTANDING UNLESS THEY'RE
TRANSLATED IT WORKING ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SO MEETING.
HISPANIC COMMUNITY. TODAY I GOT
TO MEET WITH THEM THEY SHOULD
LEADERS UNDERSTANDING.
TRANSLATED. OKAY SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
WEARING A MASK. CREDIBLE
INDICATION OF THE AMERICANS WE
HEARD FROM YOUR UNIVERSITY. THE
ADVANCES THAT YOU'RE TAKING IT
TO THE. IN ADDITION TAX IT
REALLY. TESTING GENERATIONAL
HOUSE. THE COMMUNITY AND- THANK.
SENATE I WANT TO THANK THE
AMERICAN YESTERDAY THE
COMMUNITY BUT AFRICAN AMERICANS.
MAKE SURE THAT MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR AND- TRANSLATED. I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING TOGETHER
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT WORDS
THAT ARE TRANSLATED INTO ACTION
WILL NOT STOP. I AM THREE. AND
I. IN TAKING RESPONSIBILITY AND
WEARING WHEN IT COMES. THE
SCHOOL DIVERSITY. STOP THE
SPREAD. ONE ANOTHER THANK YOU.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE SCIENCE
AND THE DATA. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP. IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
TO SPEND TIME WITH YOU. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO GET INTO THE-
YOUR TIME NEVER GAVE. PUBLIC.
YES PLEASE. WE RECEIVED
QUESTIONS FORTY FOUR HOURS. WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED.
MEDICAL PERSONNEL. DONALD THAT
VERY QUICKLY ONE OF THE-
ASPECTS ASIANS RESPONSIBLE LAST
MONTH ORDINARY NUMBERS.
NATIONAL GUARD MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. YOUR. WHAT MICHIGAN
OR ELSEWHERE ACTUALLY ACTED.
MILITARY MEDICAL PERSONNEL SO-
THE SECRETARY AND I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON AIRFORCE TO. WITH
THE LEADERSHIP THAT. PERSONAL
ARE AVAILABLE. IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN UP AND MOVING OUT. ON THE.
HELP IS ON THE WAY. THE DETAIL.
YES PLEASE.
WE SAY THAT OUR IT
WOULD BE A THAT WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN. ARIZONA OR ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE. OUR NATION'S
RESPONSE A CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
EARLY ON RESURRECTION NOT ONLY
DID WE- TESTING NOW AT THIRTY
THREE MILLION. MORE NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND YESTERDAY.
PERSONAL. PRESIDENT MARSHALL OF
AMERICA RESPONSE. WITH THE
STRONG LEADERSHIP OF APPLE
LOCHER. MAKE SURE THE STATE'S.
BECAUSE IS FIRST IN WASHINGTON
OR WHETHER IT HAPPENED IN THE
GREATER. WHAT CITY AREAS IN
GERMANY CONNECTICUT LOUISIANA.
MICHIGAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN ALL OF
THOSE AREAS THAT WERE IMPACTED
BY RISING CORONAVIRUS CASES.
THAT MIGHT. PERSONAL PROTECTIVE.
IN JUST AS IMPORTANT THAT'LL
LATER THIS. NEVER HAVE TO MAKE
IT. BETWEEN RENDERING HERE ONE
OF THEIR PERSON. AT THIS POINT
THAT OKLA TEACHER TOLD TODAY
THAT. STARTED THIS WITH.
ROUGHLY THOUSAND IN THE
NATIONAL STOCKPILE. VERY SOON
WE WILL HAVE NEARLY FIFTY.
VENTILATORS TODAY. NO AMERICAN
REQUIRE IS NOT A VALID THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST. FIVE SURE
TO GO TODAY HE'S GONNA HAVE
WHATEVER TAKES WHATEVER IT
TAKES. MORE PERSONAL. YEAH THE
REPORT WE RECEIVE TODAY SET OFF
AND ARIZONA. HAVE THE CAPACITY.
WE HAVE PERSONAL OF CHECKING.
LITTLE BY LITTLE GUYS AND MAKE
SURE THAT HAPPENS EVERY ARIZONA.
FIVE I HAS.
ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT PRESIDENT MARSHALL. ALL IN
ALL TOP MARKS. IN AMERICA WHICH
ARE GREAT. EARLY ON IN THIS
CHALLENGE. THANKS FOR BEING
WHICH ARE BEING DEVELOPED AND
RESEARCH RECORD. BUT ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR APPEARED
LATE PERSON LIKE ME IS THE
MEDICINES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL
BETTER. GOVERNOR OF THIS WEEK
FORMIDABLE RECEIVE ANOTHER
ROUND OF PROTESTS. PART OF THAT
KELLY HAD. CALLED THE STATE'S
HAVING VERY POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
HELPING PEOPLE WITH. FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS MEDIA ADVENT OF THE
STEROID TREATMENT THAT HAS BEEN
UTILIZED TO GOOD EFFECT HELPING.
OF COURSE THE CONVALESCED PLANS
FOR PEOPLE OVER A MILLION
AMERICANS FULLY. CORONAVIRUSMAY
AND I WOULD I WOULD DO ON.
CORONAVIRUSMAY POLICE RECOVERED
CONTACT YOUR LOCAL RED CROSS.
THEY SO THAT YOU CAN BE A PART
OF PROVIDING THAT WAS CALLED ON
TO LISTEN TO PEOPLE IT WOULD
ALSO PROMISING RESULTS ON THE
SUBJECT EVENTUALLY. SURE YOU.
PRESIDENT INITIATED OPERATION
PORT CITY. BUT IT'S NOT SO THIS
WORK NOW THE BETTER PART OF A
HALF A DOZEN VERY PROMISING
THAT SAME. WE AND THE WHOLE
POLITICAL THE END OF THIS YEAR
C. NO COMPROMISE ON THE SAFETY
OF THE VACCINE. GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS THE PRESIDENT'S MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO WAIT FOR HIS. WE GO THROUGH
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT CLINICAL
TRIALS. WE HAVE PROMISING
RESULTS WHICH WE DO. THEY
PRODUCE THOSE VACCINES WHEN
THAT. FILES WERE COMPLETED AS
EARLY AS THIS FALL WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE THEM. HIS
PARTNER. ALSO HUNDRED OF
MILLIONS OF. PEOPLE CAN BE
CONFIDENT WORKING EVERY DAY TO
DEVELOP. IT'S AVAILABLE THOSE
VACCINES WERE ALWAYS GOING TO
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING WOULD. IS
IT SAFE FOR THE AMERICAN.
GERMINATION. ANOTHER ONE OF OUR
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
THEY'RE EVEN OUR SCIENTISTS SAY
FROM THE EARLY RESULTS THIS
WHEN WE HAVE ACCESS WE HAVE WE
HAVE A VACCINE. EXCERPTS FROM
HER. YES PLEASE. YEAH. THE
RISING CASES. WHITE HOUSE FOUR
ZERO REAL BELIEVERS PRESIDENT
TRUMP HERE'S- SITTING DOWN WITH
PEOPLE THAT ARE LEADING THE
EFFORT IN TEXAS OVER THE
WEEKEND OF THE- BECAUSE WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY DETERMINED TO MAKE
SURE. IN ARIZONA AND THE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. THE RESOURCE LIST.
WE RENDER THE CARE THAT ANYONE
OF US ONE WANT. I MUST TELL YOU
TODAY I CAN'T THE REPORT THAT
HIS SIDE. REALITY IS THAT THE-
BRIEFING THAT WE RECEIVED
TODAY. HOSPITAL CAPACITY
REMAINS WITHIN MANAGEABLE
LINES. 85% OF HOSPITAL BUSINESS
WELL BEFORE 88% OF ICY ROADS.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE CASES
ARISING. BUT AS WE SURVEY.
OSSICLES ACROSS. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. AFTER THE
END OF MONTHS OF LIFE. SURE
THAT IS THE CASE WE DON'T EVER
WANT ANY HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL MAKING A DECISION.
HEALTH CARE DOESN'T THIS
AMERICAN MAKE SURE. HAVE THE
FOOT. HAVE THE SUPPLIES AND
ALSO AT THE THERAPEUTIC
MEDICINE SURRENDER CARE. TWO OF.
THAT'S OUR ON GOING YEAH PLEASE.
WHAT'S THE CONCERN.
WHITE HOUSE
SPORTSMAN ONE EDGE. THAT WAS TO
SAVE LIVES. AT THE END OF THE
FORTY FIVE DAYS. THAT WAS A
STABILIZING OPEN UP AMERICA
AGAIN. WE'VE BEEN WORKING AT
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. I DON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME THINKING
ABOUT. FRANKLY THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP. FOR THE END OF
JANUARY. AT ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUSMAY. WE MARSHALED
ALL RESOURCES ON THE RESOURCES
OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY. THE
SCALE TESTING. MORE THAN THIRTY
THREE MILLION PEOPLE WE
LITERALLY. SEE THE DISTRIBUTION.
BILLIONS OF SUPPLIES THAT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WE'LL WE'LL- GET A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND FAMILY. IN A
HUNDRED DAYS MAKE SURE. FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ALL ACROSS
THE- IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THERAPEUTICS AND MEDICINES.
YEAH IT. I THINK. THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT PRESIDENT
TRUMP AS WELL PRESIDENT AT
LEADERSHIP. AND WE'VE SPARED NO
EXPENSE. ALL TOGETHER ALL THE
RESOURCES. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY. ABOUT ABOUT ONE
MORE. I WAS NEVER BRIEFING
ABOUT THAT MATTER. I'M NOT
GOING TO DISCUSS. I WILL TELL
YOU. HIS FIRST THREE YEARS AND
ALSO BEING THE FATHER OF THE
UNITED STATES MARINES SAILORS.
I COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD. THIS
PRESIDENT'S ON GOING EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT OUR MILITARY WOULD BE
HISTORIC INCREASES IN MILITARY
SPENDING. LOCAL WEATHER DATA
DECISIVE ACTION WAS PRESIDENT.
TO TAKE UP THE LEADER OF ISIS.
YEAH SOLOMONIC PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S NEVER IS TAKE ACTION.
THE LIVES AND- SOLDIERS SAILORS
AIRMEN AND MARINES HE NEVER
WILL. ONE MORE ON TOP. OKAY I
CAN. BUT. YEAH ONE MORE.
WE'RE
HERE IS BECAUSE OF THE RISING
NUMBER OF CASES IN ARIZONA AS
WELL AS THE RISING COST. IT'S
VERY CLEAR WHERE COMMUNITY
SPREAD IN THE STATES MUCH OF
THE SUN THAT'S THE REASON WHY
WE- WANTED TO BE HERE TO
RECEIVE A BRIEFING. BASICALLY
IT'S ALSO WANTED TO BE. SIX
RESEARCH SUPPORT STEPS TO SEE
ANOTHER PROFESSIONALS DEVOTED
TO AFFECT. REGULATE CERTAIN
GATHER. EXCERPTS MOVEMENT. WE
EVERY KIND. GOVERNOR LOCAL
OFFICIALS ACROSS THE STATE.
YEAH GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT YOU DID BEFORE. TO BE ABLE
TO ALL THE SPREAD AND- OUR
OBJECTIVE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS EVERYTHING THE
DEBATES. THIS CALL. ONE OF OUR
FAMILIES ON THE SURFACE IT'S
SIMPLY A CALL ON THE PEOPLE. WE
ALL HAVE A ROLE. WE ARE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER. RECOGNIZING THAT
THE HEARING I. THIS IS A GOOD.
WHAT IS INDICATED OR ONE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS NOT POSSIBLE
EVERY. SO DO THEIR PART. I DO
BELIEVE THAT JUSTICE ARIZONA
AHEAD IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THIS
DEMOCRATS. FOR ONCE AGAIN LEAVE
A WAY THROUGH THIS RISING TIDE
OF CORONAVIRUS CASES. THE MOVE
THE STATE FORWARD IN THIS
ECONOMY MOVEMENT. INSPECTIONAL
THAT'S ALRIGHT. THIS ONE OF THE
YOU GOVERNOR AGAIN AND HIS
SISTER. THERE ARE. LEADERSHIP
UNDER PAR WITH YOURS AT THE
SAME YOU EVERY DAY. THAT DAY
WHEN WE PUT THE CORONAVIRUSMAY
THANK YOU.
UHHUH.